i
[Música]
a
las circunstancias que rodean el
asesinato del presidente de haití job en
el mois el pasado miércoles siguen
arrojando más incógnitas que certezas la
implicación de al menos 26 colombianos
en el magnicidio ha generado la polémica
en el país suramericano puesto que al
menos 15 de los miembros del grupo son
ex militares del ejército nacional
retirados en los últimos cinco años y al
menos uno estaba implicado en los casos
de falsos positivos como se conocen a
los asesinatos de civiles a manos del
ejército durante el conflicto colombiano
para hacerlos pasar por bajas de combate
hasta el momento el director general de
la policía colombiana anunció la
identificación de 21 connacionales 18
están capturados 3 murieron en la
captura y el resto permanecen prófugos
confirmó también que se encontraron 19
tiquetes de avión que cubría la ruta
entre colombia y república dominicana-
comprados con una tarjeta de crédito de
una empresa radicada en miami las
autoridades colombianas alegaron que
están cooperando con la policía de haití
desde el terreno para las
investigaciones para hallar el papel de
los mercenarios colombianos en el
asesinato algo que el ministro de
defensa diego molano calificó como un
hecho sin precedentes
[Música]
agentes del fbi y del departamento de
seguridad nacional ya están en haití
para evaluar la situación y ofrecer
ayuda en la investigación y en seguridad
y es que el gobierno de haití le pidió a
eeuu 500 soldados para proteger entre
otras cosas la infraestructura los
puertos los sistemas de energía y los
aeropuertos intervención militar que no
está contemplando el gobierno de joe
biden a pesar de que en 1915 en 1994
eeuu se intervino militarmente en haití
por otra parte el departamento de estado
confirmó que la policía nacional de
haití también ha solicitado asistencia
para la investigación recordemos que en
mayo de este año yo bailé no otorgó
permiso de trabajo y de vivienda
temporal a 100.000 haitianos debido a la
difícil situación que atravesaba la isla
cifra que podría terminar aumentando
[Música]
tras el asesinato al presidente de haití
rené lo hizo una de las reacciones que
más esperaban a nivel internacional era
la de francia emmanuel mack como recibió
a moix en diciembre de 2017 aquí en
parís en el elíseo sin embargo manu no
se pronunció directamente encomendó esta
tarea a su ministro de relaciones
exteriores ronnie verle otra reunión que
publicó un escueto comunicado en sus
redes sociales en este pues en nombre de
francia daba sus condolencias a la
familia móvil y también al pueblo
haitiano además de esto condenaba el
asesinato que calificó de acto cobarde y
pidió que se esclarezcan los hechos
además de esto pues solicitó a todos los
actores de la sociedad haitiana que
mantengan la calma en medio de este
contexto de seguridad tan inestable y
pidió también a los ciudadanos franceses
presentes en ese país la mayor prudencia
[Música]